quisiera preguntarte en primer lugar por
supuesto que representa para la
población el fbi de eeuu esta decisión
no ciertamente es un paso histórico
porque hay personas que sufren discrimen
por el mero hecho de que no se
identifican con ninguno de los dos
géneros que conocemos que es masculino y
femenino y pues cuando van a entrar a
algún lugar son por ejemplo cuando están
viajando son sometidos
e invasiones a su privacidad y a su
identidad y esto claramente pues
representa un paso de avance para que
esas personas puedan tener una vida
digna sin discriminación y que puedan
tener acceso a documentos oficiales que
los reconozcan como personas más allá
del género con el que se identifiquen o
no se identifiquen ahora pedro en
algunos países que tomaron medidas
similares hubo algunas críticas desde
ciertos sectores de la población lgp y
qu ocurrió por ejemplo en argentina
cuando se presentó el documento de
identidad no binario en ese preciso
momento un hecho abrió el debate un
debate muy interesante alguien gritó no
somos una equis somos personas no
binarias travestis a género o sea hay
gente que no siente que su identidad sea
respetada con una equis que tienes para
decirles a estas personas
nuestra comunidad tiene diversas
opiniones así que hay gente que va a
estar de acuerdo como gente que no lo va
a estar lo importante es que las
personas tengan la opción tengan el
derecho tengan de verdad
esa decisión que puedan tomar de cómo se
quieren identificar a aquellos que se
quieran identificar con la md masculino
con la fs femenino pues tienen esa
opción y aquellas personas que son no
binarias que no se identifican con
ninguno de los dos géneros pues van a
tener acceso a esta opción y eso lo que
hace que abre la puerta para evitar el
discrimen para evitar que haya una
invasión a la privacidad y que las
personas se puedan sentir cómodas con
los documentos que los identifican como
como seres humanos como ciudadanos y
como personas verdades valiosas que
merecen en verdad el mismo trato ante la
ley ahora a pedro contaremos que falta
todavía en eeuu para seguir avanzando en
términos de adquisición de derechos para
la población lgp y más
y nos falta muchísimo el congreso de
eeuu tiene que reconocer el acta de la
igualdad que le daría las protecciones
tanto en vivienda como en educación como
en acomodo público a las personas el eje
vehículos sino también hay que adelantar
el hecho de que todavía siguen
asesinando al igual que en el resto de
latinoamérica y muchos otros países del
mundo a las personas por el mero hecho
de ser por su orientación sexual o su
identidad de género así que todavía
queda mucho camino por recorrer para que
podamos tener una equidad completa y que
las personas puedan vivir en paz y en
libertad verdad sin importar su
orientación sexual o identidad de género
así que aunque hemos avanzado mucho
aunque estemos en verdad por el camino
correcto todavía queda mucho odio allá
afuera y todavía hay que corregir muchas
inequidades en nuestras leyes y en
nuestros estatutos para que podamos
tener esa plena equidad que nos
corresponde como ciudadanos y que se
haga valer esa garantía de la
constitución
que no se viole la dignidad de ningún
ser humano por su orientación sexual o
identidad de género